so if you haven't figured it out I'm not
giving a code talk today I'm the talk
that got brought in to give your brains
a break because we've been doing some
really dense stuff since this conference
started really really complicated just
fairly involved talking about all these
languages and how they work so I'm gonna
not talk about that it'll be great
what I am gonna talk about is tech
leading so let me tell you what that
means to me it's a term that is used at
least in the States
I think in other places and sometimes
it's a title that's a lot of times it's
like a project role so maybe you're a
tech lead on this project but then
you're just like a normal civilian on
other ones and it's I think really well
encapsulated by this quote so the tech
lead is the owner of the technological
vision of a product or of a project and
they're the technical leader of the
product team project team so what that
means is that it is different from some
other roles that might sound similar but
aren't quite the same say a product
manager who is deciding what goes into a
product who is making calls who is
figuring out what features were gonna
write who is maybe talking about how
we're gonna write them in the order but
they're not writing them that person is
not almost ever implementing the things
that they decide that we need similarly
a p.m. a project a project manager might
be very involved in figuring out you
know how are we gonna get this thing
done we're trying to get this done on
the day-to-day we're trying to implement
it
but what they're not going to do is the
technical part and then you've also got
like a senior developer who is
definitely involved in the technical
part is definitely part of figuring out
how are we doing this what a stack are
we using what language are using what
are we going to build that lasts what
are we gonna build that's kind of
throwaway for right now but what they're
not figuring out is the how do we get it
done they're not necessarily looking at
that big picture of the project
they're very focused on one part of it
and that part is likely very complex
it's likely based in architecture but
it's just one part a tech lead is a
little bit of all three of those things
so it's somebody who sees this bigger
vision for what a project can be and
what it is and they have and you know
bigger vision for what it is and they
have the context around it it looks a
little different everywhere so every
differe place has a different set of
like expectations of liberals it makes
it kind of hard to talk about this stuff
so I'm picking language that like works
cuz we need a shorthand but again please
translate this into whatever works for
you there's a different set of
expectations and deliverables everywhere
maybe you write the code maybe you have
to figure out requirements maybe you
have to talk to clients or stakeholders
or users maybe you have to launch the
thing maybe you don't maybe you don't do
any of those maybe somebody else does
them but the bottom line is part of me
at the end of the day it's about making
good software with a team because there
are a lot of things that change from
company to company tons of things things
that change from even team to team
within a company and if you're not
working on software at a company now you
have a whole new set of variables but
the one thing that is consistent on all
software projects that you ever work on
is that there are people involved and
people are similar in more ways than
were dissimilar we're governed by fairly
basic psychology most of the time which
means we're hackable which is good
because we like to hack things so if we
approach our projects realizing that
they're comprised of people and the
people need to be figured out as much as
the code or as much as the language or
the stack we're going to be more
successful no matter what our title is
or where we fit into this ecosystem so
I'm gonna give you three different
tactics to help you think about how
we're gonna do this and it's gonna be
full of specific things that you can
take back to your teams or your
wherever's or your open source projects
or whoever it is that you need to
manipulate into writing better software
with you
and hopefully you will be able to
manipulate them using these tactics
so one facilitate to advocate and three
motivate so facilitate help your team do
their jobs your job is to help other
people do their jobs to advocate you
need to keep the big picture and mind on
a project so it's really fun to talk
about all of the specific implementation
stuff but we also need to see the wider
context and three motivate figure out
how to get your team to the best
possible result I am going to go into
deeper detail on all of these but this
is sort of our roadmap this is the
scaffolding that we're gonna use as we
go through this so first to move things
forward we're gonna facilitate your job
now used to help other people do their
job if this is what you do if you're in
some kind of leadership role in a
project you're there to help other
people get something done so you want to
be removing roadblocks you always want
to be saying what's next it's a great
sin to leave someone blocked if someone
on your team is unable to work the
overall efficiency of the team is
completely reduced so you have to be
going after the things that are keeping
people from working making sure that
they can get into the get reget Hub repo
making sure that they have credentials
for whatever servers they need to be on
making sure that their development
environment is ready before their first
day starts at least to the extent that
you can do that for them you want to get
things out of the way but more than
removing roadblocks because that's
reactionary right someone comes to you
and says I have a problem and I can't
get this thing done more than removing
roadblocks you want to anticipate them
perceive the need is a phrase from
Minnesota which how to explain
Minnesotans to a roomful of people
who've never heard of them so it's a
it's a culture where it is fairly rude
to ask
for something it's very implied oh I'm
really thirsty oh wow I really like your
sweater what they're saying is give me
some water and give me your sweater so
it's it's a culture where you sort of
imply and because of that it is polite
to try to anticipate what people are
going to need so they never have to ask
you so it becomes a sort of like back
and forth guessing game of figuring out
how to satisfy people's need so they
don't have to be rude so here's here's a
story my I was at my brother-in-law's
house and I was eating pretzels and they
were delicious and they were salty so I
wanted a glass of water so I turn around
to ask and he's standing there with a
glass of water and I'm like oh hey
that's funny I was just gonna ask you
for that and he goes I know pretzels are
salty and it was really weird but then I
married in so I guess it's not like that
wasn't too weird but it was weird
so you want to do the same thing for
your developers if you can for the
people on your team you want to make
them uncomfortable with how prescient
you are at perceiving their needs and
anticipating what they're gonna need so
if a developer and your team is gonna
need an API key to get work done on
Friday don't wait for them to ask you
just go apply for it on Tuesday if
they're gonna need access to some server
ping the admin now make it a game where
you try to get in front of whatever
could stop them and see how long they
can have an unbroken streak of
productivity thanks to you
one way to help with this that I really
really like is using tickets hours and
burn downs and if we have any PMS in the
room they just got like really excited
because the programmer said that they
like burn downs but I do I love burn
downs they are ammo for a conversation
about this isn't happening fast enough
their data
I love data I love estimates because it
takes some of the emotion and the
guessing out of these conversations
about how long is it going to take to
get something done and how are we doing
when you leave a motion in a
conversation it just it can turn into a
back-and-forth it can turn into a no I
don't think so well I do well I don't
well I do and now you have nothing but
if you have some data like some
estimates that you've all agreed on and
you've put them into the system and
you're making burned downs out of them a
burned-down chart by the way if you're
not familiar just realize that maybe
that's again not a concept that
translates it's a it's a chart of the
hours left on a project and as you
finish tickets it goes like this
in theory but what it really does is it
goes like this and then this happens and
then you find something else but
eventually the great the the overall arc
is that one day you run out of hours to
finish so you want to use these as ammo
in these arguments so when a boss comes
to you and says hey we we wanted this to
launch actually next week so can you
make it launch next week instead of
being like no you can say no here's the
burndown we have three weeks left of
work so now we have to figure out what
we're gonna do about that so it gives
you something in these conversations
where you have sort of maybe a power
imbalance where a boss can be like no
because I said so you can come back with
well I have data so what are gonna do
about it
and now you at least can have a
productive work through this cuts do
this thing as opposed to just being like
well I guess we're all working 24 hours
a day
you want to know the answers or at least
where to find them because people are
gonna come to you with everything now
cuz that's your job your job is to know
things and even if it's not explicitly
your job the longer you work somewhere
the better your rep is and the more
projects or pieces of software that you
accumulate the more everybody is gonna
come ask you for things so it's not
actually possible to necessarily know
everything but you at least want to know
where to point people I think of myself
as kind of like being a router where
people are like how do I and I'm like
ask Sam they're like how do I ask Jenny
and I just send people off to the place
with the information that they need so
then I don't have to answer the question
or even necessarily know it but I look
really smart if you know who has the
information or where they can find it or
you can teach them to Google for
themselves by giving them the right
keywords to look for or suggest a
resource
you've helped move them along at the
cost of what ten minutes of your time
people are gonna come ask you for advice
so you may as well have strategies about
how to deal with this but you do need to
think about overall team efficiency
because yes if you get interrupted the
cost to ramp back up again and get
focused that is very real very real cost
but on the overall team efficiency
measure it might still be worth it so if
someone asks you a question they take
ten minutes to try to figure it out and
then they come and ask you and you take
ten minutes to work on it and then they
leave and it's 20 minutes for you to get
kind of back to the point you were at
before that's forty minutes but if they
would have spent two to three hours
trying to figure that out on their own
in the aggregate the team is more
productive it's just at the expense of
you so it's a different way to look at
our a job but it's a very important role
on the team because in general it's
going to keep everything moving along
it's just at the expense of our own code
which we'll talk about a little bit
later
but your job is to be interrupted now so
I'm sorry however it is fine not to know
something but never ever admitting it as
an excuse I don't know should burst
joyfully from your lips followed by but
I will find out this is a quote from
somebody who will be very mad at me if I
call him my mentor he's someone I used
to work with he made it really clear to
me that he was not my mentor but he's
really smart so I listen everything he
said anyway and I think this quote is
amazing one because it shows you exactly
how he talked all of the time but two
because it's true
you don't have to know everything you
can't know everything you should admit
when you don't know things and I realize
that that's maybe scary for some people
because I have trouble with that that's
again basic human psychology but what it
means is that you have an opportunity to
go forth and find the information and
this is great because you should use
this not just as a way to answer the
question but as a learning opportunity
so for example at the agency I had to
work with DNS a lot for every single
client I had to do something with DNS
but I didn't work with it often enough
to really learn it so I had to go talk
to the admins and say this client needs
to transfer DNS where should we host it
we need to put it on this server that
server are we gonna manage their email
all of these things and when I went to
them I could have just said give me the
answer like here's the situation please
tell me what to say to go talk to their
admin so I don't look really dumb but
instead I said what's the answer and
please explain why and that meant that
over time I became a lot better at
answering those questions and the admins
loved it because they didn't have to
tell me the same thing over and over
again and if there's anything sis
admin's can't stand it's that so I got
to learn this stuff and now I'm an
independent consultant and I don't have
an admin to ask so that's really good
because I use this all the time but it
means that I was getting increasingly
better and that's job security so you
want to be accumulating new knowledge
as much as you can second point to do
things right you want to advocate so
advocate for your developers for the
budget for the client for whoever's not
in the room and remember that all
software does have clients it's just
maybe users or it's maybe the other team
that's going to that's requesting the
software from you but there's always
somebody who is at the end of that
process that you can keep in mind part
of me so we want to advocate for whoever
is not in the room to do that you need
to have the ten thousand foot view in
your head so you can make decisions
about what to do on the ground and what
that means is if you have the full
context of the project then you will be
better able to deal with all of the
different levels of advocacy that will
come up so you want to try to know the
whys of decisions not only the what's
but you're only human so I recommend
that you write everything down write
down every conversation that has any
impact on anything
write down conversations in hallways
write down conversations that you have
over in meetings where something's
decided send recap emails send like a
lot of recap emails these can save you
and the reason is that they save us from
something that I call again in a
cultural reference that might not travel
we'll find out Groundhogs Day meeting
syndrome which is a Bill Murray movie
where you wakes up every day having the
exact same day over and over again
groundhogs day meeting syndrome is when
you go into a meeting and you are all
there with very strong opinions and
you're arguing about how to implement
something and by the end of it are the
end of the conversation
no one has strong opinions because all
of you are completely demoralized and
exhausted but you've at least decided
something and then next week you have
the same meeting because somehow no one
remembered or more likely
the one person who matters doesn't
remember I had a manager like that once
a wonderful man made us have the same
meeting all the time so if you write
things down and you send recap emails
and you explain look we already decided
this and here's why when you get back
into those meetings when you get in
those situations or someone wants to
rehash something you have evidence you
have a paper trail you can pull it up
and you can say hey this is what we did
and that's why we did it and the why is
important because how many times have
you had a conversation where you were
able to say hey we decided to do it this
way and the other person goes I don't
know why we would do that that doesn't
make sense we should really do it this
way it's like you were there I don't
understand so if you can write down your
explanations you are more likely to
avoid these kinds of situations
so how to advocate when talking to
whoever's not in the room right so first
when you're talking to developers you're
advocating for the users the clients
management business realities so you're
talking to other devs and they are gonna
want to build things really fancy
because that's what we do we really like
building fancy things but we don't
usually always have time for fancy
things so you have to remember to bring
people back and give them a reality
check of like look we got to get this
done in two weeks or hey you want to
make this thing but here's the context
of why we decided to do it that way and
that's where this understanding the big
picture comes in you want to be able to
give developers context and information
about why you're making the decisions
you're making because we as smart people
and developers are a little ornery a
little standoffish
we like to fight so when someone comes
and says do this my instinct is to be
like no but if you come to someone and
say hey this is why we're doing this
here's the story here's what the client
needs they're more likely to accept the
answer without a fight and - they might
have something
they're smart that's why they work there
with you
they're probably smart no they're smart
that's why they work there so if you
give them the information they might
come up with something you didn't come
up with which would be great
cuz now they're making your job easier
when you're talking to management your
boss your boss's boss the PM who talks
to the boss you want to advocate for the
developers for the code and for the
users most of the time they're thinking
really hard about the user or the
stakeholder whoever it is so what you're
really doing is advocating for
developers and that's when you want to
say the code has standards for a reason
right
so we're we're gonna not let the tests
we're gonna not not write tests we're
going to build it this way because
writing it any other way would be
miserable and we don't want to deal with
it for the rest of time we are going to
make sure that what we're doing is
advocating for the health of the project
and for the health of our lives going
forward and finally when you're talking
to clients you need to sometimes just
say no sometimes people want something
and you have to be able to be like mmm
no no no and that can be hard depending
on your relationship with whatever you
consider your client but that's making
sure that this thing will get done in
time when you say no to any of these
people though I strongly recommend that
you don't just say no say no but no but
if you give me a week I can add that
feature no but for another $10,000 we
can absolutely build that no but we're
gonna need three days of exploratory
before I can even come back to you with
some sort of realistic estimate of what
that's going to take and at that point
they might say cool because it's
important to them or they might realize
that nothing in life is free and you'll
find out it wasn't that important to
them and they'll be like oh yeah
nevermind I don't want it enough to pay
for it but most importantly you need to
say no to feature creep that
advocating for the project I kind of got
a reputation at my last job for being
like no you can't do this out of scope
no that's out of scope no that's out of
scope too and there was one day that
developer my team came up to me and he
was like hey I was thinking I know that
we're just writing this feature by the
way I signed NDA's non-disclosure
agreement so all my stories are like
someone did a thing and then someone
else did another thing so I'm I'm sorry
I can't give you details um but the
developer came about to being he was
like hey I want to write this I know we
talked about this solution but with
another like 40 hours we could write
something that is really really gonna
like take us all the way but I knew
you'd say no so I didn't even ask and
then he just turned around and walked
away and it was amazing I was like I'm
so proud that's good that's good I got
my team thinking about these things too
so you want to be able to say no because
you need to ship this code and if you
keep adding features you'll never ship
it to get things done thirdly and lastly
you need to motivate people we know from
psychology experiments that the most
efficient effective form of motivation
is intrinsic so what that means is you
can't just tell people to do things
which most likely we in this room don't
have the authority to do anyway we don't
have the authority to say you need to do
this this is your job because we're
probably peers with these people were
trying to motivate but that's really
good cuz it means you can't cheat means
you got to do it really well see I don't
want to scare you but tech leading is a
form of management it's the good kind no
it's the kind where you're genuinely
trying to help people do their best work
and motive find what motivates them so
that they will do it you might be able
to be a better manager than your manager
if you do this stuff well oh sorry wrong
button friends so the first key to this
is your attitude you are going to set
the tone for the team no one can be more
Optima
stick than you no one can be calmer than
you so if you're panicked your whole
team is at least that panicked or more
if you're pessimistic if you think that
this project will fail your whole team
also thinks this project will fail so
you need to figure out how to be oh ah
sorry not my normal clicker you need to
figure out how to be chill much like I
just wasn't you want to figure out how
to be the wall in front of the the water
that all of the crazy runs into hits you
splashes on the ground and your
developers are behind you happy calm and
dry if you can figure out how to guard
them from the nutso masa nations of what
makes a software team run at a business
then they are going to be more
productive and they'll like you better
and that's always a nice bonus so my
third tactic is passive-aggressive
whiteboarding and here's what I mean by
that I'll tell you in a story so another
team I was working on we were working in
a very large system it was ecommerce
plus plus and there was one part of it
that I was pretty sure we weren't like
worrying about enough we weren't taking
seriously enough so I kept trying to
talk to the developer working on that
part being like hey I really would love
if you started this part earlier because
I have a sense that it's it's bad you
know we're gonna run into trouble and he
was like no no no it's fine I figured
out how I'm gonna do it I'm not worried
about it I'm gonna do these other things
first and I would be like well I would
really love and he'd be like no we're
cool and that's it I mean we're what do
you do from there I said I think he said
he thinks he's the one doing the work so
I had nothing so after a couple weeks of
this and totally freaking out what I
ended up doing was I got him in a room
and I said hey can you just whiteboard
for me show me how you want to do this
and what I found is that if you ask a
developer to explain something they're
really into and especially something
they wrote that makes them look good you
can't get him to shut
up so got him in the room I said can you
show me how you're planning on writing
this and he was like yeah sure
so he's writing and I'm like oh what
what about this one and he goes I'm good
I got it
and he did so he's writing out how else
and I go well okay but what about he's
like got it
and then I go well okay but what about
and that was the moment that I could see
his face
simultaneous realization you know a
light bulb above his head and just dread
because he realized what I had to
suspect it already
he knew it at that point and so he was
motivated by his own fear to go and
figure that part out but it was
something that I had been saying for a
while and it just wasn't working he
wasn't hearing it so this is a really
really useful way to get people to know
what you already know here's the reality
of this the paradox here is that you're
not writing the code but it's your
responsibility if you're in charge of a
team so now you have to get people to do
things but you can't tell them to do
things but if they don't do them you
look bad it's a really really messed up
chain I'm selling this job aren't I I
know you want this job now but there are
things that you can do to make it better
and they're the things we've just talked
about the last thing that I'm gonna
recommend that you do is minimize risk
so you've got to go after the parts that
scare you the most whatever looks like
the scariest black box whatever you want
to work on least that is probably the
thing you should start with and you want
to look for answers until you're not
scared of it you want to look for
answers until it is not something that
you don't understand because those are
the places that are going to have the
Dragons those are the places that are
going to trip you up and you're gonna
put them off for a long time because
they're scary and hard so those are
things like the new hotness JavaScript
why
that your developer wants to use those
are things like the language you just
learned about this weekend that you want
to go right home you want to write about
these are the language that your
coworker decided they want to write in
but you don't care about you got to
figure these things out finally I just
want to acknowledge this before we
finish it can be hard to code when
you're a tech lead because coders work
on the makers schedule but tech leader
on the manager schedule the makers
schedule is long chunks of time for
hours at a time focused uninterrupted
but managers they work in half an hour
box they have meetings they have coffee
as they interrupt people they have
stand-ups so if you want to do both
these jobs it's hard and you have to
figure out how you can make them fit
together and you need your leadership to
agree they need to also understand that
your code output cannot be as high as it
once was because now your metric is the
whole team your metric is not your lines
of code it's the team's lines of code so
don't try to hold yourself to the same
standard you were at before you won't
succeed and you'll just feel bad it's a
different kind of job to lead a team to
review facilitate advocate motivate help
your team's do their jobs remember the
big picture and guide people to do their
best work thank you very much